you know it's not an exaggeration to say
country to rein in health care spending
is really going to determine our fiscal
future yeah health care more than any
other government entity is really what's
driving our debt you know to put this in
perspective the Congressional Budget
Office has estimated that over the next
50 years the government's projected
spend 37 trillion dollars more on health
care they're gonna take in in taxation
no way to put that number in perspective
in order to fill in that gap we'd have
to raise the top marginal tax rate to 92
percent you know at that point we start
making Sweden and Denmark look like a
clambake and that's the issue that were
confronting and so what we've done in
this this London School of Economics
Yale report he's try to sidestep the
politics and explore what Governor
Romney and President Obama are proposing
to do to the US health care system so D
essentially there are three core
challenges that the US healthcare system
is facing first and foremost is this
question of access you know right now
we've got 45 million Americans okay
about 16 percent of the population who
don't have access to insurance coverage
and clearly this has dire consequences
for these individuals but it also dries
up health care spending for everybody
else and we pay more when those
individuals access the health care
system and we have to subsidize
uncompensated care and when those
individuals ultimately become part of
Medicare they cost the system more money
because essentially treatment is more
expensive than preventable now the
second issues that we spend
significantly more than any other
country on health care about 15 to 20
percent of our income goes towards
health you know that compares to about
10 percent in most other rich nations
and the issue the third issues it's not
entirely clear that despite spending
more we get better quality now at the
end of the day we've got life expectancy
in the u.s. that falls below Greece and
Spain a hundred thousand people each
year die from medical errors
ends up being about the sixth leading
cause of death in the United States and
we can't go on in this situation where
we're spending more and getting less
if you were re-elected President Obama
would fully implement the Affordable
Care Act which he passed during his
first term now the Affordable Care Act
really has twin aims okay the the first
is to make the US healthcare system more
efficient to reduce long-term spending
and the second is to expand access so in
order to make the US healthcare system
more efficient what what President Obama
is really proposing is to to do to
healthcare what Walmart did to the
manufacturing industry and that that is
to use the position of the government as
the single largest player in the health
sector to prompt providers to really
step up their game so first and foremost
he's changing the way he's paying
providers okay right now we have a
system that pays for quantity they're
hoping to shift that towards paying for
quality so for example if you're a
hospital with high readmission rates or
high infection rates what we're gonna
see is you're going to be paid less
under the Affordable Care Act now on the
insurance front in order to expand
coverage the president has done three
things the first thing that he's done is
mandated that everyone come in and buy
insurance and this is really with the
aim of getting these markets to function
more effectively you know what we don't
want to see is that folks who are
healthy waiting to get insurance until
they get sick and and really free-riding
off the system the second thing that
he's done is he subsidized insurance
coverage for the folks who previously
couldn't buy it and the third thing that
he's done is is expanded federal
programs and regulated the insurance
market okay so that insurance companies
can't do things like discriminating
against individuals because they have
pre-existing conditions or or placing
lifetime caps on insurance coverage so
that you know when you got sick we're in
the middle of your care insurance
somebody can't come in and say stop you
you've reached your limit and the final
thing that he's done is is try to make
the insurance market much more
transparent okay so that you as an
individual can compare plans across
different companies if you don't like
the care that you're getting now the the
coverage choose to switch and the whole
idea here is predicated on this notion
that that markets for health care are
different than markets for for tomatoes
or any other commercial goods and that
they do require government intervention
Governor Romney has a very very
different proposal when it comes to
health care what he said is that first
and foremost on day one he will repeal
and replace the Affordable Care Act now
what he's argued is that the federal
government should have a much smaller
role in health policy and that really
the the states should come in and take
over now what he's proposed is switching
Medicare and Medicaid from being defined
benefits to being defined contributions
okay right now the government dictates
the the package of benefits that you
receive hip replacements knee
replacements certain surgery certain
medications and the challenge is when
those items become more expensive over
time the government's on the hook for
more and more money each year well
governor Romney's proposing is to to
give individuals a defined amount that
gets bigger over time but that is
limited in its growth rate and the idea
is that that cost pressure will slow the
growth of health care spending over time
and the third thing that Governor Romney
has proposed it's turn Medicare into a
voucher system so you could take that
money from the government and if you
weren't happy with your Medicare choose
to purchase insurance from the private
sector and and that has the hope of
using competition as a vehicle to reduce
healthcare spending
at the end of the day health care
spending is is really what's driving our
deficit so whomever is elected president
in 2012 this is the challenge that
they're gonna have to face Governor
Romney and President Obama have proposed
two very very different visions governor
governor romney has really proposed that
states should take the lead
whereas President Obama has argued for a
much stronger role for the federal
government and really the the debate
between the two is this question of how
do we make markets in health care
function more effectively
okay President Obama has argued that you
do need a strong role for the federal
government in doing things like
mandating insurance coverage and and
changing the way we pay doctors to get
the system to work more efficiently and
contrast Governor Romney has argued
essentially for Less regulation to give
more control to the states and allow
competition to to be the vehicle in
unregulated markets to drive change
I tend to come down on the side of the
Affordable Care Act it's not a perfect
piece of legislation but I like to think
of it like the foundation of the house
it isn't pretty to look at it isn't a
complete project but what it does is it
builds a street creates a structure for
us to build on and and that's what we
need ultimately in the long term to
begin to get health care spending under
control